all right put your hands together 59 hey
hello everyone we are team 9 the kinetic
catalysts and I'm wondering teachers and
parents in the room have you ever
noticed this phenomenon where sixth
graders come into the school year all
bright-eyed eager to learn some creators
starting to get a little bit less
interested and eighth graders are just
like totally checked out to school too
cool for school that's the problem that
we want to address we've got three
different kinds of learners who are
feeling disconnected for three different
reasons one kind of learner just doesn't
understand what school has to do with
their everyday life another might be
feeling too advanced and like they've
got passion interests that just aren't
being explored and a third kind might be
feeling like they've gotten the message
that they're just not good students
they're not successful and so why should
they care and so what we've the broad
strokes of what we want to do is to
re-energize middle school using design
thinking and project-based learning so
we've developed a program called
catalyst and the three main components
of it our teacher development sequence
learning and then a system of supports
so this whole program would be kicked
off with something called a design athan
we're viewing the program sort of as a
one-stop shop for teachers who want to
do project-based learning so the design
athan would be where teachers and
designers would get together to develop
project ideas and we've developed a
sequence of what this program would look
like from six through eighth grade and
so you'll see there's a design of fun
during the summer before each year and
students move gradually towards becoming
more autonomous and self-guided in their
project based learning we also developed
a system of documentation and reflection
that happens on an ongoing basis and
that's used as assessment and also can
be accessed by other learners and
educators so the supports that our
teachers would get include and hopefully
innovation labs within their schools
online learning communities where they
can share what's working and what's not
starter kids to get them going on these
projects modules and finally an expo
celebration where everyone can share the
work they've done
all right then thank you so much great
can I get T so this is 29 can I get teen
said what's the dissemination plan for
getting us out into the wild it's a
great question so I currently work in
the bronx with about 44 new york city
public schools so we would absolutely
love to start there we have a lot of
teachers who are looking for ways to
innovate their practice so teachers
would we basically recruit teachers to
participate and they would sign on
obviously the schools and the
administration would need to sign off on
this and we would want to develop a
system so that the we're following a
track of students and gradually building
capacity capacity over the three years
sorry hope is that those initial
teachers would become like ambassadors
spreading the message about this program
to other teachers within their school
and to other communities as well what
what I'm sorry you know what is the
motivation of teachers to become
recruiters for this process I think if
they see the the value of the
transformative power of design thinking
and project-based learning within their
own classrooms they're gonna be excited
to share that message they complain
already that day all the time is already
taken but it only takes a few minutes to
tell a friend about a great experience
in school there's also we've like plenty
of teachers right now sorry Colin voice
who already care a lot about trying game
from a project-based learning and they
just don't know where to turn to like
it's been mentioned before and so we
want to be able to generate projects for
different subjects in different age
ranges where people can know okay
there's been a symposium with really
smart people trying to figure out the
best answer to this problem we can just
go to there and see what their solutions
were and that's how we can really get or
not about this school are they just
building curriculum in out I Dorothy
also
building your own skills yeah it's
actually both so they're they're
developing actual curriculum to
implement and then they're also gaining
skills for design based design Bri
design based look approaches to learning
so they're getting more comfortable with
it they're getting to experience it
first in themselves not unlike the
design shop